Хіба не такою має бути "непорочна" жінка? Її гімен, її дівоча пліва незаймана.
Її "квіточка" не зірвана.
Вау! Який безневинний шматочок шкіри! Кажуть, це ознака невинності.
Але раптом з'являється чоловік.
Озброєний своїм - назвемо це "ножем".
Ця світла невинність - дівоча пліва - зруйнована, знищена назавжди!
Яка кривава втрата!
Прокиньтеся! Адже це - цілковита нісенітниця!
У реальності ви ніколи не втрачаєте свою дівочу пліву.
Це Лайя Вальс Перес. Вона - гінекологиня.
Її не потрібно розривати. Оскільки це не суцільна мембрана, що прикриває вхід у піхву.
Просто подумайте: як би дівчатка могли мати місячні, якби піхва була зовсім закрита?
Пліва знаходиться десь тут, біля входу в піхву ...
Дівоча пліва більш схожа на кільце з дуже еластичної шкіри. При сексі або мастурбації вона розтягується.
Якщо її не розтягувати якийсь час, вона просто повернеться до своєї початкової форми.
Вона може виглядати як смужка тканини з отвором у центрі, у формі кільця, півмісяця або навіть з багатьма отворами, як сито.
Але є й дівчата, в яких дівоча пліва справді повністю закрита.
Це досить рідкісне явище. Закрита дівоча пліва може викликати проблеми при менструації, не дозволяючи крові вийти з піхви.
Але це не страшно. Потрібно лише звернутися до лікаря, який трохи привідкриє її. І все буде добре.
Найважливіше: абсолютно природно і нормально, що у вашої дівочої пліви є отвори.
А також - що ваша пліва завжди буде з вами! Ви її не втратите! Вона лише розтягується, але залишається на місці.
Тому всі ці розмови про розрив дівочої пліви - цілковита нісенітниця.
Це чистої води абсурд! Забудьте про це! Все це брехня.
За виглядом вашої пліви ніхто не зможе сказати, незаймана ви чи ні. Це просто неможливо.
Вона може бути розтягнута з іншої причини. Наприклад, через активні заняття спортом.
І все ж... Існують спеціальні дорогі операції з відновлення дівочої пліви.
Вам обіцяють склеїти або зашити отвори у вашій пліві.
Ці операції - нонсенс. Не існує єдиної форми дівочої пліви. Якщо ніщо не розривається, навіщо щось зашивати?
Деякі дівчата також засовують у піхву капсули зі штучною кров'ю, щоб імітувати кровотечу при буцімто "першому" сексі.
Невідомо, з чого складається ця червона рідина.
Піхва дуже чутлива і складна частина тіла. Не варто запихати туди предмети, які можуть бути токсичними.
То чому ж у деяких дівчат і жінок трапляється кровотеча під час першого вагінального сексу?
Згідно з дослідженнями, таке стається лише у половини жінок.
Насправді в дівочої пліви не так багато кровоносних судин. Це кров, швидше за все, з ран на стінках піхви.
Дівоча пліва може кровоточити, якщо ви не акуратні.
Якщо секс занадто швидкий, грубий або недостатньо змазки.
Але так бути не повинно.
Проблема в тому, що коли всі навколо говорять, що перший раз буде боляче і буде кров, ви навіть не будете намагатися бути обережним.
Так що просто розслабтеся, будьте обережні, терплячі і отримуйте задоволення!
І не дозволяйте чоловікам думати, що їм потрібно грати роль "лицаря з мечем".
Тому що їм там нічого рвати або ламати!